fue denunciada a la familia de ana frank
por otra familia judía
esta es una nueva hipótesis basada en la
investigación dirigida por este ex
agente del fbi vince panko que fue
contratado por unos documentalistas
neerlandeses para intentar resolver uno
de los misterios que condujo a una de
las tragedias más notorias del
holocausto durante dos años anna frank
estuvo escondida con su familia en un
piso secreto en ámsterdam para escapar
la deportación tiempo en el que llevó un
diario pero en agosto de 1944 su
escondite fue descubierto y la familia
fue deportada desde entonces se han
propuesto diversas hipótesis que van
desde el azar hasta una posible denuncia
tuvimos que estudiar todas estas
opciones mi equipo y yo trabajamos en
todas las hipótesis posibles para
explicar cómo pudo descubrirse este piso
conformar la investigación duró seis
años y finalmente se seleccionó una
carta anónima esta carta fue enviada al
padre de anna frank el único
superviviente de los campos de
exterminio después de la guerra y afirma
que un tal vandenberghe un notario judío
de ámsterdam entregó a la familia de ana
frank para salvar a los suyos los
herederos de las memorias de anna frank
la cautela con esta nueva hipótesis
no no creo que podamos decir que el
misterio está resuelto todavía faltan
piezas que hay que estudiar antes de
poder decidir el valor que le damos a
esta nueva teoría los documentalistas
neerlandeses dicen ser conscientes del
malestar que su teoría puede causar la
de los judíos que denuncian a otros
judíos ante los nazis un historiador
belga especializado en la época advierte
no debemos confundir el objetivo los
responsables siguen siendo aquellos que
establecieron el sistema exterminio de
los judíos de europa